on the night of February 13th 1021 the
6th Fatimid caliph and 16th Imam of the
Smyly Shia Muslims al Hakim be umbrella
left his home in the capital city Cairo
he alone ventured to these city gates
and then went outside maybe to take a
walk maybe to meditate we don't exactly
know what we do know is that al Hakim
never returned home that night but
disappeared from history never again to
be found the figure of Al Haqq can be
Amidala already a central figure to the
east smiley Shiites would hold an even
more prominent position in the religion
of the Jews the Jews are a fascinating
religious minority in the Middle East
that is very sort of isolated and
secretive they are situated primarily in
the region known as the Levant
in modern countries like Lebanon and
Syria and there are many questions
surrounding the Jews like are they
Muslim are they not Muslim and people
answer these questions very differently
both within and outside the group itself
what is clear is that they originate in
Islam and specifically in a smile ism
and what is this my lissom you may ask
well I have a couple of videos on the
subject that you can watch but in short
terms is smile ism or the Smiley's are a
branch a sub branch of the larger sort
of denomination of Shia Muslims the Shia
generally followed the Imams or
descendants of the Prophet Muhammad
through his daughter Fatima who are both
worldly and spiritual leaders in a line
of succession beginning with Fatima Ali
the smileys branched off from the other
larger branch called the ethnicity or
Twelver group over who should succeed
the fifth or sixth imam ja'far as-sadiq
now those who favored his older son
ismail i binge effort became known as
the Smiley's and a couple of centuries
later these Smiley's had managed to form
the Fatimid Empire which at the sort of
at the height of its power ruled much of
North Africa from Egypt and also parts
of the Arabian Peninsula
now what's very interesting about the
fatimids is that the key lifts of the
fatima dynasty were also the Imams of
the smiley community so they served a
kind of double function in that regard
and this brings us back to the key
little Hakim be umbrella who as I said
was the sixth caliph of the Fatima
dynasty and the 16th Imam of the Smiley
Shiites and so he was a very important
person when he was alive as the ruler of
an empire and also as the spiritual pole
and highest authority to the Smyly
community already before his mysterious
disappearance he was highly revered by
his Miley followers but particularly by
a certain group of people who viewed him
as a bit more than just a regular Imam
there had been tendencies within Shiism
to apply certain divine or non-human
qualities to the Imam but these
particular followers of al Hakim began
to see him as an actual manifestation of
God on earth and as the awaited Almighty
was a messiah like figure very common
particularly in Shia Islam these ideas
have the earliest evidence in to is
smiley or proto do s-- missionaries or
also known as Dai associated with al
Hakim whose names are mohammed al de
Rossi and Hamza and Ali bin Ahmed
al-hasan II who seems to have held this
idea while Hakim was still alive but the
relationship between these two and their
doctrines is a disputed issue some claim
that that as he actually held more
extreme views that al Hakim was divine
and that Hamza didn't and that then that
us it was executed for this so by some
juice and and others that us is viewed
actually as a heretic even within the
faith and Hamza as the actual founder
and what these people actually believe
isn't all that clear some believe that
they saw al Hakim has actually divine or
a divine manifestation at least others
say that Hamza at the very least did not
view it in that way
but these things are very unclear and we
don't know exactly what actually sort of
happened at that point it's not clear
whether this was a radical break with
Smyly tradition or simply as a
continuation of already established
doctrine that is if these people
consider themselves to be creating a new
religion or just extending the already
existing is Smyly faith in my opinion
the later is probably the truth as the
ideas or many other ideas expressed in
the Jewish faith are also at least in
some form present in Shia Islam and
particularly in in the smile ism but
others have competing ideas about this
as well for example these scholar David
Breyer writes quote the exaggeration of
the importance of the Imam the stressing
of his non human qualities and the idea
that a new era was beginning were
nothing new in a smiley history though
it remained for hamza to forge them into
an entirely new religion this new era
that he mentions is related to the
conceived role of Hakim as almighty the
messianic figure so the period of his
rule is seen as a turning point in
history and a final victory for the
doctrine of God's oneness tawheed after
which a new era is instigated however as
we talked about in the intro al Hakim
suddenly vanished
one night in 1021 this played pretty
well into established Shia theology as
he was then considered to have gone into
occultation or hiding as he will return
at the end of time and this is a very
common theme in Shiism and one that is
held by many group of Shiites including
the largest Twelver group who all
believe that different imams are the
macd who have gone into occultation and
will return hakam's successor on the
Fatima throne and the smiley imamat a
guy called Ali Zaheer was very different
from his father
in fact he reversed many of the ideas
and innovations that Hakeem had put in
place and completely rejected a group
that saw Hakim as a manifestation of God
in other words the groups that we call
the Jews today here begins a period of
great persecution and oppression of this
group by the Ottoman caliph which would
lead to them being more and more
distinguished from the larger Smiley
community as its own new movement and
this persecution forced many of the what
we call Jews into other regions like the
Levant and would also very much affect
the theology and world
that the Jews would hold or develop
indeed many argue that this is one of
the reasons that in the year ten forty
three that is 22 years after hakam's
death missionary work officially ended
for the Jewish faith and after this no
converts were ever allowed into the
religion this is of course similar to
other religious minority groups that
I've discussed in previous videos as
well it seems to be a very sort of
returning common theme thus from this
moment on the Jews were confined to the
families and the insiders at that point
and so things like marriage outside the
faith has been strictly forbidden ever
since since the Jews are rather isolated
group and much of their teachings are
kept secret we don't really know that
much about their beliefs or teachings
and not much scholarly work has been
done on it at all as they stem
originally out of Ismaili Islam they are
essentially a monotheistic religion and
have a strong emphasis on God's oneness
also known as tawheed in arabic in fact
they have often referred to themselves
as the Mujahideen which means those who
profess monotheism or those who profess
oneness their view of God is one
completely beyond attributes even
essential ones like wisdom and knowledge
as they are seen to be part of his
essence and this is similar to other
theological schools within Islam like
the MOA tasoula or these smileys for
that matter they focus Laden's mysteries
and esoteric teachings and esoteric
readings of sacred scriptures like the
Quran which is known as to wield and to
exert the hidden meanings of Scripture
which is known as baton through this
process of to wield over the years the
Jews beliefs how of course changed and
developed most probably and I have taken
influence and inspiration from many
different sources
these smileys in the Middle Ages were
highly influenced by the philosophical
school neoplatonism and so we can see in
the Jews faith that this sort of carries
over here as well this means that they
have a view of God in creation where the
divine emanates in stages like a
fountain where the level above overflows
into the one below God himself and sand
this scheme but the first part of this
emanation or fountain is called the
universal intellect and after this there
is the universal soul followed by the
word or calaman which then emanates into
the procedure a Sabich and finally
succeeded at Tolley importantly while
al-hakim is seen as a manifestation of
God this should not be confused with
them viewing him as an incarnation of
God these are very different concepts
the the Jews don't view hack him in the
same way that Christians view Jesus for
example or Hindus view Krishna Rama it's
a kind of it's a different perspective
it's a different theological standpoint
they also believe in the transmigration
of the soul or reincarnation after death
and this is that some to argue that the
Jews have been influenced by religions
outside the Middle East like Hinduism
but but in my opinion this could also be
a direct influence from a smiley Muslim
currents for example the secretive is
smiley group called the Iguana Safa the
brethren of purity also believed in a
kind of reincarnation of the soul
important aspects of this being
carnation teaching of the juice are that
a juice person who dies is always reborn
as a juice and so this community is kept
intact even after death as it were so
while the teachings are the juice are
obscure and difficult to pin down some
scholars have put together certain
important themes HZ Hirschberg and
others summarized it through 7 articles
of faith 1 veracity in speech and the
truthfulness of the tongue protection
and mutual aid to the brethren in faith
renunciation of all forms of former
worship and false belief reputation of
the devil and all forces of evil
confession of God's unity equations and
God's acts no matter what they be
absolute submission and resignation to
God's divine will in both secrets and
public now there are different variants
of this list these articles of faith and
different translations and so on but
these are these are general articles of
faith that the Jews are often said to
have
similar to Muslims the Jews are
encouraged not to drink alcohol or eat
any pork most of these teachings obscure
and secretive as they may be stem from
canonical sacred texts that the Jews use
as their source these texts are
collectively known as the recital hikmah
or the epistles of wisdom of which there
are 111 collected into six volumes and
probably written sometime in the 13th
century these texts have certainly not
been allowed to be accessed by outsiders
of this religion it's only in the last
century or so that academics and
researchers have been allowed to access
some of these texts but not even all
Jews have been allowed to access these
texts historically the Jewish community
have for many periods of history been
divided into those who are considered
initiated or wise mystical and those who
are uninitiated or ignorant jahil only
those in the initiated group have been
allowed to access these sacred texts
possibly an attempt to keep the
teachings from being altered or spread
outside of the Jewish community other
religious texts are also important to
the Jews like the Quran or even the
Bible which they see asked to have sort
of conveyed the true teachings of
monotheism but that people have later
misinterpreted and corrupted these texts
an interesting example of this is that
the opening chapter of the Quran known
as al-fatiha
is recited by the Imams and Jews
weddings
the Jews House of Prayer is called the
halwa and is usually located in the
outskirts of Jewish villages and here a
kind of weekly or regular service is
usually held on Thursday evenings or
Thursday nights which is attended only
by those in the initiated group the
appall these buildings are also
sometimes used for more community
political or social events at large
another common practice of the juice is
to make a pilgrimage to the grave of a
prophet or a important holy figure this
is known as the hora much like in Sufism
for example and one of the most
important or most common of these
Giada's or pilgrimages is performed to
the grave of the Prophet Shuaib or is
thought to be located in Israel a holy
site like this is called a maqam which
literally means station and is visited
to receive blessings or even things like
health or to cure certain illnesses much
like another religion Star also certain
holidays are a celebration or events
connected to certain important life
events like marriage or funerals perhaps
the most important festal of the year is
called Eid al-adha not to be confused
with the Muslim holiday of the same name
it is preceded by the ten-day period of
sort of regrets and contemplation
followed by a sacrificial day of
festivities community and often charity
the juice started around the rule of
al-hakim in Egypt but have historically
been located primarily in the region
known as the Levant in countries like
Syria Lebanon Jordan and Israel the
relationship between them and the for
the most part ruling Sunni elites
haven't always been that great there
have always been the discussion or
debate amongst these Muslim scholars on
how the Jews should be conceived or
viewed some viewing them as an very
extreme form of Shia Islam while others
see them as apostates and heretics
altogether
needless to say there have been periods
of great persecution oppression and
unrest within the Druze community and in
their relationship between or with other
groups in the region for example the
famous hanbalis scholar eben tamiya
often a hero to modern fundamentalist
groups issued a rather nasty fatwa in
the 14th century where he calls for
armed jihad against the group and states
that quote they are heretics and
apostates his repentance cannot be
accepted rather they should be killed
wherever they are found and they may be
cursed because of what they are but it's
very important to remember that this is
of course the most extreme case and that
many Muslim scholars historically and
today have favored a more liberal
approach and emphasized peaceful
coexistence they're having periods
during the Ottoman Empire for example
when the Jews were allowed autonomy and
even protection by the Ottoman Sultan in
the last century with the appearance of
ideologies like nationalism pan-arabism
or pan-islamism aspects of the Jews
religion had been we conceptualized and
some have emphasized their similarity to
Islam and ethnicity as Arabs but also
with the many periods of unrest in the
region today this has led to increased
persecution the war in Syria for example
and the unrest related to it has led to
the Jews among many other religious
minorities being targeted by
fundamentalist groups like the Islamic
state who are often inspired by even
Tamiya and his fatwa that I quoted but
the Jews still remain a pretty strong
and significant community an estimate
show us that there may be around 1
million Jews in the world today what we
should remember however is that the Jews
are a complex religious community that
has a very long and fast
in history we know surprisingly little
about them and they're teaching some
practices much because of their secrecy
and historical isolation and so much
what I have said in this video is very
much open for discussion and can be
observed count 'red by other arguments
for example many scholars previously
have focused on the ethnicity or race of
the jews trying to make the juice an
ethno-religious community like the
Yazidis for example but most scholars
they agree that the Jews are f / both
ethnically and culturally very diverse
and so these questions of race and
ethnicity scholars don't think that
those aspects should be emphasized as
much in the case there's a lot more we
could discuss but I will leave it here
for now and hope this was a good and
interesting short introduction let's
continue this discussion in the comments
as always and if you want to support
this channel you can like the video and
subscribe to the channel I'll see you
next time
[Music]